it's the third largest country in Africa
45 million people live there and
strategically it's really important
lying just below Egypt I'm talking about
Sudan and in recent years the country
has become a flash point in a battle for
influence between Russia and Western
Powers especially the United States
but this weekend the country erupted
into violence fighter jets screamed over
the capital cartoon firing Rockets into
a city of Millions
generals who four years ago were part of
the same regime are at the center of
this crisis they're now at War fighting
for control of the country
so what's going on and why is the
International Community so concerned I'm
Sally Lockwood and this is this Sky News
Daily
I'm going to be talking to an aid worker
who's based in the capital of Sudan when
I spoke to him on Monday there was
shelling in the background my staff and
friends they have incidents where
bullets have hit their windows and and
chapmans have ended up in their rooms
that's the current situation
but first our Africa correspondent user
Elber game on the political situation
this is also very personal for you sir
she's from Sudan and has family caught
up in the crisis
my parents are currently trapped at home
I call them frequently to find out how
they're doing and I this morning heard
gunfire over the phone while I was
talking to my mum and it was it was
really loud and this isn't just
something that I'm experiencing this is
people around the world so these people
in the UK in in countries all over and
and calling trying to reach their family
trying to to make some sort of contact
but I think the main fear that we all
have is that we can't see an end
we don't know how this is going to turn
out the UN proposed the humanitarian
safe passage of three hours between 4 pm
and 7 PM just so that people could leave
their homes and get supplies and food
and whatever they needed and the gunfire
continued and my mom this morning told
me that she heard of a student who was
killed during that safe passage because
I told her you better not leave the
house we don't know if this will hold
it's Panic it's fear but most of all
it's uncertainty it's this real deep
fear of the unknown not only how long
this will go for but where this will go
how bad it can go the concern is that
Sudan could descend into all-out Civil
War how close are they to this point
closer than ever before this is what
people have been concerned about the
airport was a key Battleground in the
first 24 hours there were air strikes on
the airport people passenger planes were
hit Saudi Airlines came out with a
statement and said that they had a
passenger plane hit on the tarmac we
received a video of passengers on board
saying that stray gunfire killed two
people on board
you've seen videos of people on the
floor of the terminal passport control
taking cover and and that idea that this
is the main airport that can get people
out of the country was a key site that's
it's been heavily damaged there's really
no hope for people to leave and you're
not only looking at people in the
country you've got Sudanese people all
over the world who have family trapped
who don't know how they'll get their
family out this is the nightmare
scenario this is just the bubble has
been burst and and the risks are higher
than ever
as usra says the situation has now
become very dangerous the risks couldn't
be higher nearly 100 people have been
killed in the violence so far including
three un Aid workers with the world food
program arshad Malik is based in
Khartoum He's Country director for the
charity save the children
I woke up with the sounds of gunfire
very loud
and since then we are hearing the the
continuity of these gunshots across
various part of the city we also heard
reports from friends and colleagues that
the fight is spread across
the entire city is it safe enough for
you to go outside can you can you get
groceries can people still go about
their lives we have been advised by the
government uh not to go outside and then
stay indoor most of the grocery shops
are not open there are electricity cuts
across the various parts of the city we
are also hearing that there's a water
series that like shortage in various
parts of the city as well
so in terms of your answering your
question whether it is safe or not uh
unfortunately no most of us have
supplies less than three days remaining
as I said some people are already
reporting lack of water
in various parts of the city
so I'm not sure how long people can
survive
and how are you getting information who
is it that's communicating with you and
how we have staff members who are in
various parts of the city we have
colleagues in other agencies this is
more of a Community Network rather than
any like organized information sharing
obviously dozens of people have been
killed dozens of civilians have been
killed over the weekend
are people worried about their own
personal safety people are worried we
also heard from our staff and friends as
I said that they have incidents where
bullets have hit their windows and and
chapmans have ended up in their uh rooms
so that's that's the current situation
so people are quite concerned about
their Safety and Security it's not just
civilians some Aid workers have also
been killed over the weekend four of our
colleagues three from world food program
and one from another peer organization
called relative International have died
our office in North was attacked last
night all the assets medical supplies
Food Supplies everything has been looted
I don't know whether you can hear in the
background shelling but uh it's it's
becoming more and more uh dangerous more
specifically to operate in uh
in parts of Darfur where the conflict
which is in khatum at the moment has
also spread there
oh if you're able to put it into
words what is day-to-day life like for
people in Sudan at the moment okay life
has come to stand still
as I said before people don't have
access to water people don't have
Russian for them to survive for another
couple of days we also heard reports
that children were stuck into various
schools we for sure know about one
school where a big number of students
children and and teachers were stuck
thanks to the local authorities in that
locality who have helped them to go back
to safety one of my colleagues is stuck
in one of the school she went with her
son to
um to the school and since then she's
not able to return she's still there we
have colleagues who are stuck in various
different places we are hosting
ourselves
friend of my daughter so that's that's
the day-to-day life they are taking
shelter wherever they can in the given
situation and of course you're already
there looking after vulnerable children
how much worse
is the situation going to get for them
next one of the major worries we have we
are really concerned about the
psychological condition of the children
children like continuously hearing
gunshots and fights fighting going on I
have heard from police that their
children are not able to sleep one of
our colleague has reported their sibling
who's like around 12 years is showing
extreme signs of stress so there there
is already an impact of well-being of
children
Sudanese people do not deserve this this
is a very beautiful country with like
excellent people I've spent four years
here I have used a lot of respect for
the communities here so we hope that the
situation stabilizes in the near future
okay back to use for now for more on the
political backdrop to this violence
tensions have been building for some
time and there are two generals at the
center of all this
on the one side you've got General Abdel
fatah al-burnan he's head of the Army
and the country's de facto president
since a military coup in 2021
on the other side you've got Muhammad
hamdan de gallo known as hemeti
he's head of the paramilitary group the
rapid support forces
now they came together to oust the
president Omar al-Bashir in 2019 who'd
been in power for around three decades
but they're now fighting each other for
control of the country so these are two
men who were in a partnership to share
power to consolidate state power in the
face of a pro-democracy movement that
ousted their long-time Ally military
dictator Ahmad Bashir they came together
after months of prolonged protests to
remove but she from power and since then
they have been charged with running the
country while the transition to
democracy Democratic elections happens
uh in the meantime people have been
fighting for a civilian rule for a
civilian government to come into play
and basically run the country there's
been a power struggle behind the scenes
since 2019 but it's escalated in recent
months and and in the last few weeks the
rsf has been operating with impunity and
movements in the north of the country
have happened without the Army's
awareness which the Army earlier last
week called a clear violation of the law
and warrant of confrontations and at the
end of last week these confrontations
came to be and they went head-to-head in
heavy gunfire in the capital and
explosions and most recently airstrikes
now as you say these two generals they
used to be on the same side and now
they're not can you explain who they are
and what they want the head of the Army
is now currently the de facto president
of the country and he is known for
having ties with islamist factions on
the other side you've got rsf
is a militia leader he is known for
being a commander of malicious tribal
militias that have been accused of
committing atrocities in the Darfur
conflict that started in early 2000 and
early 2000s 2003. Sudan as you've been
describing has been under military rule
for some time now but they were due to
transition to democratic rule soon that
hasn't happened though has it I mean the
Democratic dream for Sudan has been a
pipe dream it's been something people
have been fighting for since as long as
I can remember my parents fought for
democracy in Sudan from Independence
from British war in 1956 but it's always
been these constant cycles of a brief
period of democracy and then military
rule the military coup that we saw in
2021 post-revolution Sudan that
Consolidated the Army and the rsf and
that removed the civilian prime minister
that came after Bashir from power was
the fourth coup that we've seen in our
lifetime since 1956 since Independence
so this cycle has been exhausting for
people in Sudan and not just in Sudan
but the many people that have left the
country that have been exiled in the
series of power you know being
Consolidated by armed forces in the
post-revolution period people didn't
stop protesting just because of Bashir
was ousted they continue to take to the
streets because they feel very strongly
that it is isn't just about one
individual it's a it's a deep State
issue that there's a military state that
is deeply entrenched economically and
socially that needs to be removed now
you said the fighting isn't just
isolated to the capital is it what else
is going on around the country
especially with the paramilitary group
The rsf or the rapid support forces
we've seen uh violence in that Ford and
this is that Ford is obviously where the
rsf have the upper hand this is where
they're from this is where they came to
power but it's also where they wreak the
most Havoc so Dad thought is is
definitely another place that we need to
watch but also the north of the country
now meadowy in the north is where the
rsf was mobilizing without the Army's
agreement and this is what essentially
triggered the Army to to put out these
very bold statements against the rsf and
again at the capital is is not only
dealing with heavy gunfire but also
airstrikes by the Air Forces now the Air
Force has told old people to stay at
home but we've seen and spoken to people
who've had shells hit their homes
damaging their houses have had bullets
penetrate the walls of their house so
even in their homes people aren't safe
and the capital has never seen this
level of warfare I think that's really
important for people to understand even
though Sudan is home to the longest
Civil War in Africa Khartoum has never
had
shelling airstrikes there's been a lot
of violence there since the revolution
protesters being killed there was a
massacre in hartdom in June 2019 where a
pro-democracy sit in in front of the
military compound was disbanded lethally
people were killed there were rapes
hundreds injured and yet this is still
the most violence people have seen in
the capital in recent times explain why
the International Community is so
concerned about what's going on the
International Community has always seen
Sudan as a fragile situation and not
just in the post-revolution period but
because of the civil war with the South
which eventually led to the secession of
the south in 2011 but also the war in
that Ford which is is one of the longest
conflicts we've seen you know
environmentally driven resource-driven
conflicts that we've seen But in general
the idea after Bashir was ousted that
there needs to be mediation between the
two strongest armed groups was always
driven by this idea that this was to
prevent Civil War and when the
revolution happened there was a lot of
talk about we don't want Sudan to be
another Yemen we don't want Sudan to be
another Libya what a lot of people feel
is that that sense of fear trepidation
around the rsf actually enabled the rsf
and I think early on uh when Bashir was
ousted we were all very surprised to see
himiti in the offices of the British
Ambassador shaking the British
ambassador's hand shaking the U.S
envoy's hand with the ambassador to the
EU all of these inter interactions
legitimized a tribal militia leader to
the point where he was looking to to bid
for presidency and it's almost a paradox
you kind of get everyone in the room to
make sure that Civil War doesn't happen
but by getting everyone in the room
you're legitimizing uh entities that can
then use that to continue to amass power
and well to the point where they have
the artillery the the weapons to fight
the army at this level as if it's a it's
an army of another sovereign country
my thanks to user Abigail and arshad
Malik and to you for listening to the
Sky News Daily with me Sally Lockwood
this episode was produced by Annie Joyce
with Alex Eden our editor is Philly
Beaumont
foreign